[Music]
don't be about dressing Francis
well Francis is one of my muses and so
when I was you know she told me she just
dyed her hair which is a beautiful new
shade and so we were talking about what
she would wear and she picked this from
the collection and I think she looks
stunning and I was telling him earlier
in the car that it looks like a
psychedelic Fraulein Maria moment and
I'll obsessed with it and I love I love
the putrid greens
I'm a doll but it's like monochromatic
it's brilliant I love sad I know you
have new music and you dropped a preview
of that music how important was that for
you to to preview and also will you be
wearing any of Jeremy's designs and
upcoming performances or videos I'm
working really hard to to make come to
fruition when I I envisioned for myself
as an artist and music is totally
included in that but I don't want to
like limit limit my just music it's like
it's visual and it's it's musical in its
audio and it's soulful and that's just
I'm working towards making all that sort
of my daily life and then sharing with
the world it's like that's part of the
contract you sign and being an artist's
is that you send it off and people do
with it what they will and and I think
that's such a cool process Frances Bean
Cobain stunned Sunday's daily front row
Fashion Awards she and designer Jeremy
Scott also posed with Paris Jackson at
the star-studded event and Jeremy has
this idea for the upcoming royal wedding
what should Megan Marco wear to the raw
wedding Jeremy Scott
well mosquito of course
do like a thigh high boot or some she's
gorgeous you can do anything I think
it's great I'm so happy for her and
happy for us as Americans to get our
little foot in that little English door
into that castle